has Rod rodeny just told us on a shuttle
pod show exactly what's wrong with Star
Trek but why we should be hopeful for
the future welcome to sidre your CI TV
and mov
[Music]
channel in 2016 while secret hyout was
developing the new Star Trek show for
paramite and CBS Studios Rod rodeny was
approached to Executive produce at the
time he had rodeny entertainment and
that actually worked on previous Star
Trek shows earlier obviously Rod rodeny
is Jean Roden BR son I probably should
mention that earlier or this is going to
be very confusing for you and after
seeing him do this interview on the
shuttle pod show to be fair the first
interview I've ever really seen him do I
have to say that he really does seem to
be trying to stand up for what his dad
set out he is the gatekeeper of Star
Trek I actually think if he had a little
a little bit more power we might have a
better Star Trek show I I do what I'm
able to do um and uh so we're certainly
a part we have a seat at the table we we
share usually when
things we kind of save it for when
things are
grossly uh missed not Trek not Trek he
actually talked in the video about how
there were a lot of people that are
involved in the creation of Star Trek
and they try to withhold their input
unless they really really have to he
talks about here about how we would only
step in when something really isn't Trek
when something really goes against what
his dad would have believed him now I'm
hoping that they kind of have a veto
that would be great if they could
sparingly of course because you know
still a business there's still a team go
in and go no yellow card red card that
isn't Star Trek come on we need to
change this that is kind of what he's
hinting at but but he also does hint
that actually they don't have that much
power in the game that there are people
there that are the main creators the
show Runners but that they can step in
when needed there does seem to be that
respect there very early on from
Paramount that actually having Rod
rodeny at the table is worthwhile but is
it or is it just a little bit of fan
service again Paramount has shown
repeatedly through secret hideout that
they are more than willing to use a bit
of service to get what they want they
know Star Trek is a very beloved
franchise and they also know that it's
quite divided so what do you do very
early on to try to get the fans on board
get Rod roden's name attached now
hopefully you give them a bit of power
so that you actually get something that
is Star Trek at the end of it that the
hopefully the
a mouthpiece and that he probably really
doesn't have that much power and that if
he did maybe particularly the early
parts of Star Trek and Discovery would
have been very different but the people
who work on it are now more there are
more fans working on the shows people
who truly like Star Trek here he's
saying about how there's a lot of fans
that actually make Star Trek I I think
he's really referring particularly to
Terry metalis how Terry metalis came in
and made Picard season 3 and he is a
Star Trek fan he desperately wanted to
do Picard season 3 and got his wish and
if Paramount want him he'll be back to
do Legacy I imagine anytime they like
but the way he says it does make it
sound like perhaps there weren't so many
Star Trek fans there before in fact I
would say everyone who works on the
current shows as they did back then love
the shows but there are the the be
encounters so to speak who need to make
money now he talks about the bean
counters now that does make sense so
there are going to be people there that
are watching The Pennies that are saying
look our viewing figures are this our
budget is this these two things need to
marry up we cannot spend a hundred
million dollars on a season if only a
couple of million people are watching it
we just can't it makes no sense we can't
do it but there are enough people there
now that are fans of the show that want
to make Star Trek now I think that means
there weren't as many fans there before
now that might be an underhanded J at
curtzman or people around that I'm not
want to put words in his mouth but it
does seem quite clear by saying that
there are more fans of the show now that
there were less before and that maybe
even though that's a good thing going
forwards it does explain a few of the
problems going backwards first of all
there's there were five shows out and
they're all very different MH um if if
you're getting into Star Trek and you
don't know which one the good news is we
got five different shows or at least we
did um and and if you don't like one try
another if you don't like one try
another um but the people who work on it
are now more there there are more fans
working on the shows people who truly
like Star Trek a big problem with Star
Trek is this attitude that there are
five TV shows so that if you don't like
one you can just go and watch
another I understand the logic of that
but that's not how it should be that
feels like you're settling now I've
always argued that pount makes Star Trek
for a wide audience I think their plan
very early on was to make a show for
this audience a show for that
demographic and a show for this gender
or whatever that you actually have shows
that are targeted at those different
demographics why not just targeted at
sci-fi fans why not just targeted at
Star Trek fans I don't know about you
but if you're a treky I have quite a
broad taste in sort of TV similarly to
music I'm mostly a rock fan I love rock
music I love the Foo Fighters I love all
that sort of thing I love Indie music
but I will occasionally listen to a
dance song I'll occasionally
occasionally a pop song will hit me and
I'll go oh my God that's a really catchy
tune I love it I really like listening
to country music weirdly I have a wide
base of interests Star Trek could have
five different types of show but still
be Star Trek and still be a show I can
watch I have desperately tried to watch
Discovery season 4 I was I I promised
the actually mark from the shuttle put
pod show that I would and I can't it's
awful I don't like it and I I just feel
like I'm burning my own time away it's a
bad show and to be honest even though it
was better than the first season the
fourth season is still a bad show I
really like strange new worlds I love
lower decks I love Prodigy actually and
I loved the third season of peard I
didn't like the first or second but it
shouldn't be that difficult to make five
different types of show that can still
appeal to me as a treky because you
could make subtly different types of
show but they don't they really do Point
shows specifically at certain
demographics like a younger audience or
what they think a younger audience are
like and then Picard season 3 at
directly at trekkies and then I don't
know whatever they did with lower deck
and Prodigy at children for some reason
I don't know why they did that and you
know they they do this in a way to try
to scattershot the entire audience it
doesn't work don't do it so no I don't
agree with Rod there it isn't you pick
and choose the Star Trek for you this is
Star Trek it should be for all of us
need to make money so do you do a show
with Talking Heads or do you do a show
with action sure and you've got to find
that balance because you are doing Star
Trek I mean and and that's where I draw
the line is is Star Trek is its own
thing and needs to be something that's
thoughtful and provocative and hopefully
at the end gets you to consider
hopefully if it's done right a different
point of view I actually think he's
diplomatically and very carefully saying
what a lot of us think about Star Trek
at the moment that yeah actually this
was made by people that didn't really
understand what Star Trek was initially
and that maybe weren't fans brought
Roden Brien I think definitely probably
at first just because of his name and
then he stuck around and probably earned
his due he now gets to actually jump in
and say when things aren't right I doubt
this is just my opinion but I doubt he
had that much power initially by his own
words he says they're very careful about
that that seems to me to say that he
knows his position is as a lower partner
that he doesn't have the authority to
step in and go no know so when he does
he has to make sure it's a battle worth
fighting maybe if they gave him a little
bit more
Authority we'd get less crap and it
would seem to me as well that he feels
Star Trek is actually going in the right
direction we're bringing in the right
people something else I think us treky
fans are noticing Star Trek is going
into a slightly Rocky future SciFi is
expensive and the audiences aren't as
big as a lot of the production companies
would like we've maybe seen a golden age
of Star Trek again and I'm just hoping
that the producers over at secret
hideout didn't waste that opportunity
because there's going to be less money
in future less Star Trek but actually if
it's made by people that genuinely love
it like rod and Terry metalis and other
people like that then they don't need to
spend that much money to create a TV
show that trekkies and others can really
fall in love with
we don't need constant CGI spinning
Starships we need a bit I love a space
battle we need a bit but we don't need
two or three minutes of that every
single episode we watch it because of
the characters we watch it because of
the adventures we watch it because of
the science fiction if they could get
back to that a little bit they could do
it for much less money and maybe if they
listen to people like Rod a little bit
more we'd get better
sci-fi so please guys go and watch the
shuttle pod show there is a link in the
description for the full video If you
really want to get a feel for what Gan
rodeny was like but also what Rod his
kid is like and the influence he brings
to the show it's a really fascinating
interview now I've got a little bit
after the credits here that I want to
show you about why I think you should go
and watch the shuttle pod show not just
because of the great guests they have
but because of these two main guys yes
they appear appeared in Star Trek yes
they were just actors when they went in
but they fell in love with not just the
show but the
philosophy this is why I love the
shuttle pod show and it's why I love
Star Trek give it a watch and go and
subscribe to the shuttle pod show this
is a conversation right I'm allowed to
ask you guys question
absolutely okay good because I feel like
it's uh keep good well so I mean you
guys in your experience with I I'm
always curious people who
what were your thoughts before you
entered the Star Trek universe during
and more so now after I mean you've had
a number of years you've you've worked
on the show I'd love to know from each
of you if you don't mind what what were
your thoughts initially you I initially
didn't have
any and I still am I not surprised by I
still seldom do I grew up my my brother
what do you feel about dog food
it's great uh you know I grew up like
most kids with the the reruns of uh the
original series and watch it go you know
after a huge my brother was a massive
fan and he and his buddies would walk
around the perimeter of the of the
school ground at lunchtime talking about
the previous day's episode now my
brother and I uh very close but very
different and so that was his thing and
then when I uh I got the show I got
Enterprise yeah he must have been really
test or jealous well he tells the story
funny thing is that so I get the job and
for those of you cple sorry but it is
funny the first person I call is my
brother who has like a one and a
three-year-old at home and he's by
himself his wife's teaching and I call
him up and I'm like Matt you're never
gonna believe this I just got cast in
the new start Lily put the Ruby stop
touching her cereal you guys I gotta go
that was the reaction that was it and I
was like oh H did he hear you yeah I'm
not he called me back later and he was
thrilled for me but at the moment it was
kind of like you know real life got
right right yeah thought' be a bit more
chuffed but I will say that you know
once the show started I didn't go out
into the convention when that's really
how I found um the uh language and the
legacy of what it all is and the
community yeah um I was terrified to do
it uh Dom went out early I did and uh
first one out and it took a couple seen
that Trey moving I was like oh yeah
there's an annuity here right I but
frightened beyond belief yeah yeah I I I
I I remember it taking a couple of years
for me and really what it came down to
is the conversations I would have at the
table with people who would walk up and
say I'm an
engineer because of your character you
got me through
a really difficult time in my life I I
was I would wait for every whatever it
was for us Thursday Saturday Sunday
depending on what day they push us
around around but but I would you know I
was going through a very dark time and I
all I looked forward to was getting
through this week to watch the next
episode and those things particularly
Dominic keting is some I hope Dominic's
in this
one uh I found myself you know really
humbled by uh what i' had gotten myself
into and awfully proud of it and and um
you know honoring and a little bit after
the fact I don't want to say completely
but a little bit absolutely absolutely I
mean initially it was a gig yeah and um
and the greatest gig in the world
because it was it was like this wasn't a
pilot we thought we were get we were we
were sh for seven years right this my
agent said like no you're doing the
first episode of your show and uh so
that was just again that was like the
golden ring that year of of shows to get
but again to your point yeah it took a
couple of years and it took
the connection to the people who really
really care about it to then that that
then bled into me and I began to feel
the exact same way and the longer I've
gone away from having done the show the
more impactful that is for me as the
years have gone by it deepens and deep
yeah I often say it's the fans who
brought me into Star Trek because I
didn't really pay attention to it but it
was was very respectful of that wasn't
she and I think she sort of Drew that to
your attention didn't she she she made
sure she went to at least one big Star
Trek convention a year the the the short
version is you know I I went to
conventions very young but again I still
didn't care because night rer was coming
on tonight and I was you know gonna see
no I mean that's that's what it was I I
I didn't get it a talking c um
yeah um your mom's the computer and you
watch a talking car I know yeah well but
what really what really did it was uh
the part that she inspired me was she
would get there and she wouldn't go in
sign with the other actors she would go
to her table and she would sign and what
I was always very impressed that she did
at conventions is that she would
interact the time with and she would
spend two three four hours there um
signing and then talking to people God
bless it was nice and it wasn't just a
transaction yeah and so like Bill yeah
you said it um
I was always very proud to see her do
that and then my father the few times
they he'd ever go to anything or or
speak on stage he didn't disappear
behind the curtain he would get down off
stage and talk to people so they they
were very human and and they kind of uh
fought for they they knew the fans are
the ones that save Star Trek and they
never took that for granted and I think
every opportunity they had they they did
what they could to thank the fans or at
least be humans with them well your your
your presence is very impactful at at
especially in Vegas and any convention
you go to and when did that start uh my
presence well I mean I I've been seeing
the same one I've been
going my eyes are up
[Laughter]
here what was your Star Trek uh what
were you like I knew what I was getting
into IID watched the show as a kid uh if
I'm truthful I had walked away from it
as a young adult in my teen years I was
not interested in Doctor Who anymore or
Star Trek but as a child as an eight
nine 10 year old I was I was mad for
Star Trek really yeah so you're one of
the Smart Ones yeah and I it was more of
an adventure show more than anything
else I'm not sure I you know was hearing
a an ethos or a tenant that you know a
societal you know message but I just
love the colors and fact it was in space
and yeah they did this thing called
beaming up and you know there were a lot
of shiffon clad ladies which was very
very interesting to
uh but like I say I'd wandered off by
the time I was I don't know 13 14 15 um
so getting cast on it um that was a as
Connor said I mean I it was a bloody
good job to get cast on because it
looked like it was a sure thing for
seven years and um yeah at least for
that year at least yeah we knew we were
gonna we knew we weren't just making a
pilot we were we were getting a run and
uh and uh you know we were at Paramount
man when it was still an incredible you
know one of the old timey Studios and uh
those those those stages and all its
history the whole damn thing was I just
pinched myself they were Housey and
salad days and they really were and I'm
eternally grateful and you guys had a
great crew too I mean it seemed like all
the shows had a great crew I don't I
wasn't really there but I mean every
story I hear yeah you know but
everyone's sort of a family member there
sure there's maybe little squabbles but
you guys come together as a family all
they've been together for like 17 years
there was a about 20 of them we were
coming on to their show yeah we were but
they but they opened their arms to us
absolutely and they treated us with all
the respect of of stars arriving in a
new show uh which was quite heavy yeah
and uh you know Marvin got impatient
with me once or twice probably for a
good reason yeah
yeah looking back on it around
Dominic
Dominic but uh I mean without a doubt
they were they were the best some of the
best years of my acting life and and of
my life in general uh and as Connor you
know iterated um going to the
conventions and seeing I remember going
to fedcon early on and stepping out in
front of 10,000 people man uh just I
mean it was like being in a boy band
yeah those German fans yeah they went
for it they love St pretty damn sure I
took my shirt off
a boy what they want a boy um at the
final one I mean God bless they pushed
me and Leonard out who was on one of his
last harras really uh to represent the
first and last of Star Trek the final
our last Harrah oh yeah um you know we'd
been cancelled and they pushed me and
him out to to represent the first and
last in front of you know another huge
crowd there and God bless him he hadn't
got a clue who I was s but he put his
arm around me and walked me out to the
center of the stage and then told that
story for the first time with where that
where he got that from yeah from being
I'm still sure sure to my soul that
George has no idea who
I yeah I'm pretty sure he'll say hi to
you and give you a hug and I'll say hey
Geor like
[Music]
hello